В Німеччині існує
три головні види виплат на дітей.
Протягом шести тижнів ДО пологів і восьми тижнів
ПІСЛЯ лікарняна страхова каса
виплачує жінці 390 євро
на місяць. А роботодавець
докладає решту суми,
щоб породілля отримала свій середньомісячний
заробіток після оподаткування.
Тож протягом двох місяців
після пологів жінка може повністю
зосередитись на дитині,
знаючи, що вона точно може
розраховувати на свою звичну зарплатню.
Одному з батьків, хто доглядає
за дитиною в перший рік її життя,
держава сплачує від трьохсот
до тисячі восьмисот євро. А точніше -
65 відсотків
від середньомісячного заробітку
без податків. При цьому держава
всіляко заохочує татусів,
які вирішать взяти відпустку із
догляду за дитиною.
Наприклад,
якщо він піде в декрет щонайменше на два місяці,
загальний строк батьківських виплат
зросте з 12 до 14 місяців.
Батьківську допомогу запровадили в Німеччині десять років тому,
щоб стимулювати народжуваність,
зокрема серед подружжів з середнім
та високим прибутком.
Адже багато німкень з хорошою освітою
та зарплатнею не поспішають заводити дітей
через страх за наслідки для кар’єри.
Щоб полегшити молодим батькам вихід на роботу,
два роки тому правила виплат
батьківської допомоги змінили.
Тепер отримати її можна протягом двох,
а не одного року. Розмір допомоги
при цьому знижується, але натомість
в перші роки життя дитини
батьки мають змогу працювати
не на повну ставку.
Вона становить близько двохсот євро на дитину щомісяця.
Конкретна сума залежить
від кількості малюків.
На ці виплати можна розраховувати,
аж поки дитині не виповниться 18.
Їх навіть можна продовжити
до 25-річчя нащадка,
якщо той - чи та - не здатен
сам себе забезпечити й мешкає під
одним дахом з батьками.
Попри солідну фінансову підтримку з боку держави,
народжуваність у Німеччині -
нижча за середню по Євросоюзу.
І майже ідентична з народжуваністю в Україні.
На одну мешканку ФРН
в середньому припадає півтори дитини.
Проте в останні 20 років
рівень народжуваності в Німеччині
поволі зростає – очевидно,
дається взнаки політика
фінансової підтримки родин. Водночас
багато молодих батьків вважають, що гроші –
не головне. Проблема в тім,
що місць в ясельних групах
та дитсадках досі не вистачає.
І поєднувати роботу та виховання
дітей в Німеччині доволі непросто.